[Music]
these wiggly lines could be
the oldest fossil animal ever discovered
while they may look like random markings
on a rock
if these are the remains of an ancient
animal it would push the first
physical evidence of animals on this
planet back
by 300 million years
[Music]
animals are multicellular eukaryotes
complicated life forms that consume
organic material
breathe oxygen and live now as the
varied and complex creatures
we see all around us but their earliest
ancestors
likely started small and kept things
pretty basic
they might have even been a sponge
okay not quite like that but sea sponges
are a kind of
organism still in existence today whose
close relatives are a good candidate for
early animals
that's because they have simple body
plans
essentially tube-like structures that
filter feed
and they have relatively few types of
cell
but determining if sponges were the
first kind of animal
has been tricky the earliest fossils
that scientists
are relatively sure are animals come
from around 550 million years ago just
before the cambrian explosion
older fossils have been quite
contentious as it's hard to work out
what's an animal
and what's not the new find would push
back the first
evidence of animals by 300 million years
the unusual patterns were found in the
northwest territories in canada
one argument that this really is an
ancient fossil animal
is the complex branching structure
similar to some modern sponges
not everyone is in agreement though it's
possible the patterns could have been
made by bacterial mats
it would have also been difficult for
animals to survive
890 million years ago this was a time
with very little oxygen but the fossil
was found intermeshed with bacterial
structures
so the organism could have lived in
close proximity
with photosynthesizing bacteria in
little
oxygen-rich oases
the fossil also looked very similar to
more recent fossils from around 500
million years ago
that are also believed to be ancient
sponges
if this really is evidence of an 819
million year old animal
it would have survived through massive
climatic changes
including an extreme cold period some
call
snowball earth while there is a debate
about the fossils animal nature
if true it could give us a new
understanding of how our ancestors
formed
almost a billion years ago
[Music]
you